LaDainian Tomlinson the Hall of Famer
NFL Network analyst who joins us did you
does that kind of fit Andrew lucky to be
driving a Honda Accord I guess I'll have
your rookie year what did you drive your
rookie year I had a navigator
okay yeah yeah SUV and uh yeah
I would think that would be for you know
your kids you know because most people
are not going to get their kids even if
you drop it is they a celebrity driver's
ed you know a BMW or what have you
most celebrities I know you know when
their kid turns 16 they start driving
they get them a Honda Accord or
something like that I can see that but
your girlfriend I don't know about that
what although she sticks around who's
who's the which teammate had the
craziest car the most expensive car in
your career we we had some guys that had
safaris it probably junior say are at
that time had you know he had the nice
cars you know he had been in the league
he was all-pro making a lot of money so
when I get when I first got there I
think journey was you know driving
around and sports cars and whatnot but
at one time I actually I had a
Lamborghini deal and so I was driving
around these different Lamborghinis in
San Diego so that was pretty fun does
Philip Rivers have a school bus
considering he's got his ninth kid on
the way yeah I know it's amazing
congratulations to Philip Rivers by the
way yeah but yeah I mean I know he used
to his wife used to she did have the you
know kind of the soccer van because she
had all those kids that's that
she's driving now I would assume it has
to be some type of van right I mean my
bus a bigger but I think Sprinter
shuttle service there with Phillip
Rivers all right let me let me start
with last night with your Chargers how
big was that win that was a huge win you
know especially obviously they're trying
to keep pace with with the Chiefs but
but in in Pittsburgh where both of those
teams pretty much evenly matched and
it's always a tough place to play in
addition to not having Melvin Gordon and
not knowing exactly what the offense was
going to look like without him well you
got to be happy for Justin Jackson
because he really stepped up last night
and helped that team but I thought the
second half was the difference the
defense really started to get a hold of
what Pittsburgh was doing and started to
make some plays Joey Bosa Derwin James
those guys really came a big when the
charges needed them what was your
reaction when you heard that she was
released Ramon you know I wasn't
surprised and I just you know in today's
world you know if you do something like
this you certainly can lie about it you
got to put it all out there on the table
and give the organization an opportunity
to do their due diligence with the truth
they're mine but you certainly can't lie
and I understand why the Chiefs did what
they did because when you lie you know
you just make everybody look bad and
cluding yourself and you see that's what
happened when once the video came out
that she had no idea that this this
happened the way that it did because
obviously Kareem hunt kept some of what
the details away from them what would
you how would you advise him to proceed
well you know I would tell Kareem to -
he needs to obviously get help he needs
to work on him
and try to understand why this truly
happened within themselves not the fact
that he regret the decision and he put
himself at a bad decision why did he get
so mad to the fact that he felt like he
had to hit a woman why you know and he
didn't answer that question so I would
say he needs to work on himself get some
help go talk to someone you know find
out truly what made him get so mad that
he felt like he had to do that
he's LaDainian Tomlinson the
hall-of-famer working for the NFL
Network and you can see him tonight NFL
Total Access at 6:00 Eastern also every
Sunday an NFL game tain gameday prime at
11:30 p.m. Eastern with Deion Sanders
did Mike McCarthy deserve to be fired
you know I think I think it was time Dan
you know that relationship obviously
with him and Aaron Rodgers running on
his course and you know we seen this
coming you know just the relationship
was too fractured to repair it and you
know once that happens you see it
affects the entire football team when
Aaron Rodgers your best player is not
happening he speaks out in the press
conference about your play calling
that's that's an issue that is a true
issue and it affects the entire locker
room and you saw that they just couldn't
they couldn't go any further so you know
at this point I wish they could have
made it to the end of the season I
expected that he will get far I
certainly don't like you know someone to
get fired during the season I just I
don't like that that doesn't look but at
the same time I think it was warranted
it was time for a change and I think the
Packers did the right thing how much
blame does Aaron Rodgers deserve well he
deserves someone to blame but you know
at the same time what what are you
giving Aaron Rodgers to play with at
this point I mean when you look at this
roster it's filled with a bunch is
second and third year players at this
kill positions when we talk about out on
the perimeter in addition to guys like
Davante Adams and Randall Cobb who else
is on there's a bunch of second your
first year guys and even on a on a
defensive side about the defensive back
position yeah you know a lot of rookies
and second-year players and you just
can't win games like that because those
guys haven't been together long enough
and for so long the Packers have
expected Aaron Rodgers to be you know
Superman and pulled them out of you know
bad situations and and go on the run
well we when the cupboard is bare you
simply at some point you can't
continuously do that you just don't have
enough talent around who goes further
the rims of the Chargers you know I
think they both make it to the Super
Bowl
I really do I said that early in the
season and a lot of people think you
know always being a homer but I just
look at these two football teams they're
complete football teams and I think the
road to the Super Bowl they both can go
on the road and win it certainly looks
like at this point the Rams could have
home-field advantage and the charges
will have to go on the road but I think
they're you know they're they're
determined to be able to go to a hostile
environment like the Patriots or you
seen last night distill this or even
Kansas City and win those games I think
it's possible and I think we see both la
teams in the Super Bowl how many
touchdowns did you have total in your
career I think that will be a hundred
and sixty two okay how many footballs
did you keep from those 162
probably about probably close to a
hundred and where are they miles I know
but but are they displayed well I
haven't found a place for all of them of
course and so no some of them are in
plastic bags just kind of sitting around
in the garage like is there a touchdown
that you're not really that proud about
that maybe you could put it on display
here in the man cave like like there's
just one you go you know what I just
walked in I didn't do anything and I got
a touchdown before you know for game
yeah but it could be a crappy touchdown
that you scored doesn't have to be like
anything no crap two touchdowns there
all of us all of the touchdowns are very
important how about one with the jet
along like but you know with the Jets I
mean those didn't really matter I mean I
could for you dad we've been great
friends for a long time and you've been
asking me for the Minnesota Vikings
Jersey I found it but I think a football
is is something that I can provide for
you now you nobody asked for the Vikings
Jersey because you didn't play for the
Vikings they just gave you a jersey
right yeah and I and so I thought of all
the great things you could have from
LaDainian Tomlinson I wanted the Vikings
Jersey that you never actually but it
looks so sweet that Vikings
purple you know it's almost like the TCU
purple yes
Thomasson on the back you know that it
looks pretty it looks pretty did you
frame that is that framed in your house
it's my friend yet it's not I will admit
but it's going up in my house because
it's such it's collector's item at this
point I know but you
roll around in the backyard get some
grass stains on it oh you played for the
Vikings one game yeah they gave me a
jersey here they gave me a jersey hey
it's great talk to you and if I don't
talk to you happy Holidays to you in the
family and thanks for joining us
that's LaDainian Tomlinson Hall of Famer
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]